[Music]
but the main thing that you need to know
about me that I have PhD in physics
theoretical nuclear physics
please stay don't go
so you hear me you'll probably ask
yourself how calm I got from doing that
and believe me I did that a lot
to doing that okay
so let's get back a little bit in time
remember 2019 Happy Times yeah yeah so
then I did my PhD in physics I did it in
the local theoretical Nuclear Physics
what I did is focusing what we called
fear body system so we're looking on a
very small system of nuclear and nuclear
interaction and trying to coagulate them
1919 I finished my PhD and moved to
trento lovely city north of Italy yeah
to do a postdoc
foreign
but the basic mechanisms stay the same
we're looking only on the Microsoft
microscopic interaction like the
tubebuddy three by the interaction of a
very big large complex system and from
that we're trying to calculate the
macroscopic feature of the system or
what we physicists like to know
solving the shreddinger equation I want
to solve the certification
but what happened after 2019 remember
2020 and I was in North Italy
I was in Milan in February 2020.
I came back after a day
remember Adam all the people came from
Italy we have to be in Cortina everybody
thought we're
sick
Israel was a mess Italy wasn't a bigger
mess and everybody would try to say
something about covet 19. physicists
started to say something about Jose 19
and said really Felix do we have
something to do with covid-19
and I said okay well I'm a physicist
right what I know how to do to calculate
too bad interaction and if think about
it what is infection it's a two-body
interaction right you have a healthy
person and we have an infected person
and if they interact
the infected person the health May
infect the healthy one and yes believe
me I know people are not particles okay
put it on the table but what if what if
we'll take the same mechanism that I use
to solve complex physics system and try
to predict covet 19.
and spider luck it works
so imagine that we have a surface with a
lot of particles each particle simulate
a person so from now on I will talk
about people not about particles and
this population can be divided into two
subgroups one of them are healthy or
because susceptible it means that people
are not infected
some of them are infected I mean they
are contagious right now they can infect
other people and the other are recovery
means they're out of the system they're
not healthy they're so they cannot be
infected anymore and they are not
contagious right now
and people are moving every day they're
moving by changing their position we are
using Monte Carlo algorithm for that
it's changing randomly
and
the more encounters that we have between
people then there is more likelihood of
infection so when people are moving
their meat if one of them is healthy one
of them are in fact there is a chance
that it's going to be an infection
so since this is an individual model
then we have a lot of flexibility
for example we can Model A very
different scenarios of infection like a
very dense one like a conference or a
concert
we can use and not really dance
a simulation like in a mall or something
like that or really really like a dilute
one like a little village in Sweden
where you likely that you see somebody
is clearly there
another thing that we can do with the
model is add more data and move feature
to it for example fix in right
in the beginning of 2021 there was a lot
of massive vaccination of the population
so we can try and say that some of the
people are protected and we don't have
to do that uniformly because remember in
the beginning of 2021 not all the
population in Israel was vaccinated at
the same time we started with the
elderly one and then moved back and then
move to the people who are younger and
the kids weren't vaccinated oh so we can
vaccinated some of the people in the
model and do that even according to
their age
another thing that we can do that we can
add like different variant so different
people are infected from different
variant and these effects are uh
infection pattern and we can do a lot of
stuff but the fact that we're using an
individual model help us to to put a lot
of features to the model
so how does it look like again on Day
first I divide my population into three
susceptible healthy infected and
recovered and every day I'm looking of
the probability that a healthy person
can get infected so this probability is
a function of his its distance
dispersing distance from all the
infected people around it which comes
into this dysfunction and also I need to
have to know how much this person is
protected for example if it's vaccinated
and if the probability is greater than
one then the healthy population I remove
one of them and the infected population
goes up with one but we need to remember
that people are not contagious forever
so some of the people no matter what the
probability is if they're infected they
are becoming recovered at just as a
function of time
so here I just put one interaction like
I have one healthy person and one
infected person but
of course we are dealing with large
population so for each healthy person I
have to take into account all its
interaction with all the infected people
in its environment and I put a different
line for different healthy people and
now it's pretty good I hope it's gonna
work
yes no yes I put a little animation
every time the yellow is changing the
health status
people are moving and then every time
you need to calculate it from scratch
the probability of each healthy person
to become infected again and notice that
we started with three healthy person and
now we are left with only one but we
have more recovered people so that's
nice
but it's not really efficient right
because this is a really really small
system so what happened like last year
the beginning of 2022 the only crane
outbreaker remember loads of lots of
people were infected
so if I want to simulate what happened
in Israel when I have like 7 million
healthy people but half a million
infected then every time I have to take
to account 10 to the 12th interaction
well in the academic you know we have a
lot of time but I don't always do that
for the Academy so if I want to do some
decision making with this model and I
want to simulate not one scenario but
one two three four I don't have time for
that I have to find a way to make this
modem be much much more efficient
so the first thing we can do is to use a
periodic boundary condition it means
that we don't take all the population we
take what we call a unit cell
and we keep the density because the
density is really what we are all in
made of and this unit cell has to have
all the information this means that they
have a lot of resolution that I need to
have in my system then I need to have
quite a big unit cell and then I'm
making a replica
for it healthy person like that
so what I'm doing I'm kind of duplicate
this unit cell and I'm keeping the
minimal distance for each healthy person
as you see here now this
now is this a healthy person now it has
low a shorter distance from all it's uh
surrounded
and if the unit cell is not pretty big
that I can put everything in the Matrix
use numpy and that works
uh but sometimes you cannot do that
because I need more resolution and then
I can use multi-processing
and so I'm kind of
sorry yeah so I'm
splitting my code into different
processing and again you need to keep
into the accounts that I only splitting
the healthy people
so infected are keeping on each
processor because the infected people
are talking with all the healthy but I'm
on but for each healthy person I'm doing
the calculation over different processor
and then I'm putting everything back
together and these initial States
turns out to that
so this is a really nice model
and yeah and I did a lot of work with it
some from academics and in the beginning
of 2029 I use this model to do a lot of
decision making for the state of Israel
and especially how kovid will spread in
the presence of effective vaccine
some of them was covered by the Press
you can see here
also in the summer 2029 if you remember
the one of the waning immunity and there
was a Delta
so I tried to see how the mobility in
Israel will be in the presence of a
booster dot how that would affect
and the mobility in Israel
see here down there and also during the
Omicron outbreak I gave some prediction
this is for example a prediction that I
give for the Israeli Ministry of Health
of what gonna be the active the number
of actives of your cases every day uh
he felt I gave this prediction I don't
have a pointer but I gave this
production in January it's a black
daughter and the red one are the actual
data that going all the way up to match
was a very accurate well
[Music]
follow me on Twitter I give some
more productive production for the kovid
even now
okay so that's nice
but you know from time to time we don't
have an outbreak so we can have time to
think about more interesting questions
from time to time you know
and the one thing that we noticed in the
subject of a vaccine is that in the
beginning of 2020 now again it really
started to vaccinate a lot of people and
then a lot of studies
came and there were like real data
studies not that you vaccinated people
that are part of the experiment you just
see on the vaccinated population how
much those population is getting
infected or not
so one of the biggest study was done by
the klalit the biggest Health
Organization in Israel and I found that
this is a red bar if they're looking on
the younger population that was done in
the beginning of 2020 now the vaccine is
very effective it's effective as 90
percent
however if they look on the elderly
population so it seems even more
effective like 95 which is a bit weird
but mostly even weirder is a Maccabi
Macabre did the same study same time
same vaccine type of pleasure they only
get 80.
which is really really weird because
it's again time fixing same population
Israel same time
why is a Maccabi is different from the
clinic and maybe it doesn't look like a
big difference but twenty percent twenty
percent Effectiveness say that the
vaccine person is protected by 10 times
25 is 20 and 80 is only five so it is
something different if they'll study and
it's not a big sin
I tell you what is different in the
quality they took what we call
population-based approach it means that
people are vaccinated and just going
around and we see every day who was
infected in Hunan makabi did something
else they use the secondary infection
approach it means that they're looking
only on a household in the family and
they know exactly for each infection who
was the third of this infection
and so maybe the different connections
that were in the Macabre study
makes the vaccine looks different from
the clinic
so we have a hypothesis of that
so maybe there is some I don't know like
indirection protection
from the vaccine the bias is the vaccine
Effectiveness so for maybe in the
Maccabi people saw the vaccinated less
vaccinated people they interact with
them less and that gave the vaccine to
look less effective
so we want to check that
so first of all we built a really simple
Network each of the network contained 25
nodes number from 1 to 25 and this
network contains five like inner Network
five clicks so what we need to know
that's a connection inside the inner
Network for each node is much stronger
than the outer so each of the network
have exactly 40 40 percent
a vaccinated their node the main
difference is the mixing as you can see
here in the left one we have a very very
low meeting this means that the
vaccinated all the inner Network are
either vaccinated and vaccinated we have
some medium in the medium Network and
high mixing in the right one so
the left one the first one can be for
example a nursing home in the beginning
of the vaccinated campaign where all the
residents and all the staff were
vaccinated and the people hardly met
and vaccinated people
however this right one can be a family
because as you remember kids weren't
vaccinated
so if we have a family of two vaccinated
parents and three unvaccidented kids
actually the vaccinated parents
meets more unvaccinated people than
vaccinated so he is exposed to her more
unvaccinated which is kindly what
happened in the Maccabi study
so
we need a very simple equation trying to
connect I'm not talking about it but the
thing that you need to know that now we
can have a connection we can have like a
feature how many people are in the inner
Network outer how many people are
vaccinated how what is your chance to be
infected inside the network and the
outside and then connected to the Russia
between your input vaccinated uh
effective to zero preserved one
and we can draw a graph because we have
scientists that we are doing and if you
see here low level mixing and here like
and we call I the level of mixing is
related to a high overestimated vaccine
Effectiveness which was like the clearly
where especially for the elderly one
right but if we're looking on the high
level of mixing we get an underestimated
because in all of this graph we gave
0.85 85 percent effective but this
translate to a Higher One in a low
mixing level
and to a low one in a high mixing level
okay not nice
but the real question is can we do like
a real modeling with real data to a
person
okay so what we did
everything everything was taken from a
public data of Israel first of all we
use nearly
1600 data that of 1 600 statistical area
which in average each of them contain
like 5 000 people
and we have that on it and the second is
that we took the basic model and we put
a network on hand it means that now for
each healthy person we have like a
circle of infection where the most
strong one is your family and then you
are moving like to a close community and
then to your remote community so and
they are the and the people of course we
have um can interact with each other and
we control the rate of vaccinating of
each person is
statistical area
and so we can for example have this one
where the people are really really not
mixed and also we have
yeah like mixing of the population and
the rate of vaccination of each
statistical area is the real rate
taken from the official data from the
Israeli Ministry of Health so we kind of
organize our area from the most
vaccinated arrays this is from the
beginning of 2029 to the one to the list
one
and we're assuming that most of the
infection are within the same
statistical area so we want to check how
the fact that the vaccination inside was
not uniformly
may affect the result of the both of the
studies
so it takes a basic model
but now
in addition to the distance the real the
real physical distance between the
people we add like a family distance so
the closer the family distance is there
is more chance of being infected and I
put it like that it's a distance of the
connection is the distance the length
but the color indicates the strong the
the family
a connection so like that
for example you see this two red
people over there
they're decent for the
healthy person is almost the same but
one of them is in a remote Community
then the other so the chance of being
infected from this person is much much
lower than the one to the twist left
and what we did for the with the model
that we arranged that half of the
infection will be inside the household
so the first test to the model is just
to see whether or not we can predict the
confirmed case because it's nice but if
we cannot predict the number then
the model is not good so that's nice
first of all we see that our model
predicts the configures in Israel really
really good and second we put the model
a lot of a different level of mixing
between people and we see that no matter
which mixing we put into system
that the model and the real data are are
almost the same but on the other hand
it's it's saying that the confirmed
cases cannot tell us what were the level
of mixing in Israel that time and we
need to find a different approach to
find that
foreign
so this is the final graph we take all
the data and for each
mixing scenario we calculate what is the
vaccinated the vaccine effectiveness
of using the data and we did it in two
approaches one is the population base it
means that for every day I'm talking all
the people that were vaccinated finding
how many people are not vaccinated
seeing how many of those uh vaccines and
unvaccinated were infected and then
calculated the vaccine Effectiveness in
the secondary approach is a secondary
infection approach I'm only looking for
each infection on its clothes infection
because I know for each person who is in
family and community and only looking on
that
and what we can see that again
like in um the analytical model
low level of mixing translate to a high
vaccine effect which really goes with
the cleat experiment is study and
high level of mixing goes with low
vaccine effectiveness
but the problem is that when we have a
study we cannot know what was the real
vaccine effectiveness
so in the secondary infection we can
know that because for each family I can
tell how many people in the family were
vaccinated how much not I can assume
that there is no infection outside of
the family because I'm only looking on
that so I can actually use my analytical
equation from beginning and then say
okay the thickness that was 80 but these
are the all the inputs so it was really
originate from 85. I cannot do that with
a population base I need to find
something else so we did it
okay so what we did we say okay we're
doing is a population-based approach but
we are only taking vaccinated family
because we don't want to mix in the
study vaccinated people working in the
family with non-vaccinated family and
with and every time we match these
numbers on the same statistical area so
we try to remove as many bias as we can
this is the dashed blue line and as you
can see that no matter what level of
mixing that we put in the system the
model was able to repredict say 85
effective which is what we put it into
the model which is really good and
they're saying that we can take this
physical model and not just predicting
uh covet and doing also very interesting
question to answer it so thank you and I
want to thank to all the people that
have been collaborating using for this
model for the last wow three years uh
starting from my host in Toronto and Dr
neon all the work that I did for the
first vaccinated campaign was done with
the huji covid-19 monitoring team and in
the Omicron we had another scientists
Steph Tim that's me
work with a lot from the technion rambam
in Libya University
and
I'm not only doing kovid also
check also monkey box and you can talk
to me whenever and you can find me on
Twitter and Linkedin and thank you all
yeah
ah okay
we'll start with one
um
this is the data from those networks and
no no I
only public only public it's a subject
to a really long and talk but no yeah
yeah there is a problem in Israel of
getting some of the data and I as an
agenda work with only data that is
available all the sources are in the top
no I'm only using like their final
result I don't have yeah this is great
the second question is
do you have an equation to be published
eventually yes do I have any question
yes well the model was published in
physics of Floyd and Pierre the physical
stuff we put on Med archive just
recently with a paper that compares this
model for each outbreak in Israel and to
the classical sir model we put a pseudo
code uh all the equations are there also
this over an underestimation is now in
under like revision and then I will put
all in the supplementary materials there
is a part of 18 equations if anybody is
interested of how you get to this final
but yes all the equations are available
and if not I will send it to you
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]